yeah my name is Kurt Viserys and I just
started on sons of anarchy you see this
here yeah Jimmy Smits is joining the
show and the sons of anarchy the
motorcycle guys in the show there
they're doing business with on part of
sugars fruit and we I can't like really
reveal anything at this points just show
us it started but um there's some what
major character gets build up this
season and we're doing business for
those guys so that's what's happening
this year yeah
so how many callbacks did you have
before I actually met them once months
went by and all of a sudden I got a call
and they said hey we have someone who
just came across our guest and we want
with straight operatives with a secret
was what you doing because they know my
work because the people that did that do
sons of anarchy do that had did the
shield and I had did two years in the
shield a very very cubes interval crazy
brawl and so they're you know what I
could do so they said hey come you sent
a man our key with us we know you're a
great actor make some great choices and
do some good for us so they brought me
honestly and how long have you been
acting
or Simpson the the 80s a child star I
was a kid okay yeah not a child starving
child actor yeah so you saw early on the
ups and downs of the business and yes I
mean yeah I took ups and down to the
business from day one but I was you know
when you're young and like whatever you
have some downs I'm just gonna I'm gonna
beat that overcome it but as you get all
the nearing starts his aqua meat to it
learn how to work with them
vulva then use it to your advantage
because you have to this funny way to be
successful and make things happen how
are you how do you learn to do that cuz
I think we're so many of us we're actors
or sensitive school that's why we're
great at what we do that's the thing is
like you use you use instead letting
emotions that are coming though and like
you know takes you away from your goal
you allow it to to push you forward and
it's like your excitement the excitement
that you that you started as an actor
one of the other
that excitement is back to you just keep
making it push you and push you because
that's what wanna do and it's like you
you have to get in the thick skin thing
you have to think skin and if you can do
that you know some people call jaded but
again it's not your jaded if you're
negative but if you are positive and
can let things bounce off then you I'd
say you've mastered how to like ride
through this business you've mastered
how to audition we mastered how to take
meetings mastered how to overcome the
emotional life together
so what's jaded and what's being a
realist shaded is negativity it really
is that we changes there's a real
essence like you know what I'm here I'm
doing what I love and why should I be
complaining because I mean I have
thousands of friends all over the world
to do other things and they all call me
like all the time
you still do
I'm just walking in
I respect you with his humor too
and you're just following that where did
you grow up in a Napa Valley okay yeah I
grew up in Palo Alto
Wow my brother okay so you were used to
a freer sort of spirits of freer mano
really
I ran barefoot through cow fields again
through creeks I mean I mean is crazy we
caught raw fish and tadpoles and we were
horses and I went I walked up to Tina
high every day through a capital that is
now full of home it makes me sad every
time I go there I'm in Napa and the
world is Saints like Napa is a microcosm
of what the world is like they used to
be just nature Russian rhythm and
openness and
now you're closed in with just
small corporate stuff angry minivans so
there's a definite shift in idea in
terms of Northern California versus
Southern California and usually the two
are sort of at war with one another when
you wanted to move to LA what some
people tell you I no one say anything
saying tell anybody okay that's the way
to do it I just Vista gimmick sounds
cliche but I literally woke up one day I
was in the little studio in San
Francisco and I woke up one day and I
said this weekend I'm moving had a
little pickup truck I threw my stuff and
I came down to LA got myself didn't know
one person and I just came here and I
just got and when I arrived us out we
weren't did I just do it was this place
is fun nothing like Northern California
there's no
they're not touchy-feely yeah they're
yeah yeah I thought well I'm here I made
this commitment and let's go and Here I
am it's like I feel very blessed because
I've I personally yeah I look back and I
came from back to where I'm at
I make a living this backyard I don't
have to wait tables and I'm pretty bored
and I came in on Facebook because it's
really to do what you love there's
nothing better
so what timespan are we talking about
from when you move down in your truck
with San Francisco spontaneously yeah
what's the true start to now north of
July Thank You Nathan
she's think you've done that now sorry
Oh what I've done
I wouldn't I would not honestly
recommend it to as much as I love what I
do and where I'm at it could be honest I
wouldn't recommend it to anybody because
it's it's it's a very taxing taxing
experimental
and this as a way of really you know
making you see yourself which is good
but it's hard
really look in the mirror and like deal
with being a day with what we are and
what's not happening
being judged everyday there's nowhere
else in the entire world
when you walk into a meeting or an
office and down the street looking I
mean here in LA we walk into the
restaurant was like I'm looking it's
like what everyone has to look look what
are you doing Segway look at those shoes
oh my gosh that shirt good belts you
know it's like and to be on a on a stage
every second one of these sounds just
hard for you people is hard for us so
again I was I was blessed within the
first few years to stuff just came and
I'm the thing is I'm a workaholic I work
hard and you know I can't I'm gonna say
that I earned what I've done because I
did you know I didn't get no life no
timing whatever but I worked hard to get
where I've done and I can safely say
that I've heard so far this
which is nice because I feel like if
someone just handed it to me I wouldn't
I take it for granted but I don't take
for granted now where I'm at I sigh like
sweet humble and help others you know I
love helping new people that coming down
like young people to come down they
always I meet them and they ask I say
call me anytime text me anytime because
I want to help if I can save you years
in your process I'll do that because I
just left healthy so and if one of these
young people calls you with sort of a
dark night of the soul like you know
what I'm gonna I want I pack it up and
what do you say I would sit there and I
would I would actually
why and then I go to Starbucks the part
whatever but I would actually go sit
with them and I prefer to look some of
the young nothing better than human
contact
we text too much we don't even copy one
Twitter you know the Twitter coming it's
like it's like yeah it's lines of text
and some look someone in the eyes 101
and see the schola but I don't see the
beauty assesses yours you know connect
with somebody there's nothing better
than that and to instill what I can as
far as wisdom and knowledge I have a lot
to learn
I'm just halfway through Mother's but if
I can help someone who I feel like
that's
to give back possible my goal is just
give back
people think in
be inspired lastly what's the best piece
of advice you've ever seen
well hi Roenick Lee had to take a class
in high school
and I wouldn't be sitting here right now
listen to that who told that to my
counselor who I wrote a letter to and I
don't know if the COTS him cuz I didn't
find know how to get to him but if it
wasn't for him forcing me my senior year
in high school to take a class that I
didn't want to take because I was a jock
in high school and I said hey I don't
want to live wear black clothes and
would make up and become you weird
I don't wanna be weird and acting and
the drama school is way off campus in
high school like I don't want to go
there you're taking it and it's changed
my life wouldn't would not be sitting
here damn and I have had the best I'm so
happy with my life the way things have
gone and you know we all have ups and
downs but you know what I've experienced
I can't